Chelsea Clinton was a key campaign
figure when her mother ran for president
last year and even before that she is a
vice-chair of the Clinton Foundation and
an adjunct assistant professor at
Columbia University's Mailman School of
Public Health she is here for an
interview you will see only on CBS this
morning her best-selling book it's your
world get informed get inspired and get
going is now available in paperback
Chelsea welcome thank you so much
Charlie great see you I'm happy to be
here well what do you hope to accomplish
with this book I hope that this book
helps inspire kids who are already
engaged in the world to think about what
they can do to translate that interest
and engagement into real action now what
can they do to help improve the health
and wellness in their schools what can
they do to help fight global warming
what can they do to ensure they're
supporting girls getting into school
around the world and I hope that it
helps some kids who maybe aren't engaged
yet think about why they might want to
get engaged particularly at this moment
yeah last time you were here you called
it a call to action actually I do
are you finding kids at all ages really
do want to get involved absolutely
Lincoln I really I think we talked about
this last time I was here I wrote this
book in part because I kept meeting kids
who wanted to know more about what they
could do and I also was really lucky to
meet so many kids who already we're
doing something I wanted to know what
they could do to make that work even
more impactful so I hope it's a resource
for the kids who are already engaged and
I hope it helps inspire some the kids
who aren't engaged yet but want to be
you were going to say so well I was
going to say that knowing this book and
good for you the question everybody
wants to know how was your mother oh
she's great I saw her this weekend we
were up in traffic law with our kids
Charlotte and Aiden I think the best
moment was when I was relaying an
anecdote from a couple nights earlier
when I'd put Charlotte to bed and she
said mommy I said yes sweet girl she
said I want to be a mermaid or a
zookeeper I said great so we laughed a
lot adoption so again and my mom talked
to Charlotte a lot about what it would
mean to be a mermaid or a zookeeper
you think she'll run for public office
again oh I have no idea
I don't think so I think right now she's
focused on her book she's focused
thankfully on her grandchildren she's
focused on what she can do to help
support work that she's been engaged in
for longer that I've been alive around
children around women around families
and I just am really grateful to have
more time with her now than I've had in
a long time I know that when she spoke
in Scranton for st. Patrick's Day though
she said I'm ready to come out of the
woods yes what did that mean well I
think we're seeing what that means right
now I mean she has given a few speeches
where she is talking about kind of what
she thinks kind of needs to happen now
she's clearly looking to encourage many
of particularly the young people who are
thinking about running for office that
they should keep thinking about that and
throw their hats into the ring she is
trying to figure out what she can do to
help support so many of the
organizations you know like Planned
Parenthood who are standing on the
frontlines to defend our fundamental
rights and I just am really grateful
that she's out there doing that work
because I believe as strongly today as I
did kind of last year and the year
before about what we need to be doing to
protect and advance progress is there
anybody else in the Clinton household
thinking about running and by anybody I
mean you see you could you could take
your book on the road while you're
campaigning with get informed get
inspired get going I feel like deja boo'
with your mom all over again you're
running are you running are you running
for what yeah no that's that's a
question that's a I don't I I do think
it's important that we be talking about
all the different ways it is possible to
engage in the world and I think being a
citizen isn't something that just
happens in an election year I think it's
something that kind of is a call to
action for each one of us Gail every
single day and I think there are lots of
ways to get involved clearly running for
public office is one of those I think to
run for public office though a few
things have to be true I think you have
to have a clear vision of what you would
do kind of in a given job I think you
have to have a clear sense that you're
the best person for that job and right
now
I'm really lucky I live in a
neighborhood here in New York City where
I support my City Councilwoman I have a
major not-so-secret girl crush on our
public advocate Tish James I support our
mayor I love my congresswoman our
senators I clearly don't agree and with
our president but I'm definitely not the
right person to run to defeat him in
2020 so right now the answer is no but I
think we all need to be asking ourselves
that question periodically and I hope
that a lot of young people going to use
the election to think wow like should I
run for public office and we're the
right person for your given job whether
it's a school board or a senator but
your Twitter account is you're using it
more than you were in the past and do
you expect to use that in terms of as as
a way to show where you disagree with
President Trump well Charlie I think
it's clear that I disagree with the
president has lots of issues and I think
Twitter is one vehicle to do that and I
hope that kind of all of us are thinking
about the different ways in which we can
going to raise our voices and try to
help ensure that things we think should
be more on the agenda or it's it's equal
pay day to day you know I hope that's
something that gets a lot of attention
I'll probably be tweeting about that
later today so stay tuned it's Earth Day
later this month I hope that gets a lot
of attention I think Twitter is one
vehicle for any of us that are on social
media to help elevate awareness and
hopefully to help kind of draw attention
particularly to areas that we think are
underappreciated or are kind of not
being addressed in what we think are the
right ways we're in the midst of a
debate about whether Russia tried to
influence the election and we've heard
from former CIA directors we've heard
from former vice presidents who say this
is the most sophisticated campaign ever
that they've seen by Russians try and
influence the election end potential
administration or the current
administration during the during the
campaign what what do you think about
what Russia did during the campaign
Lenora you know what I know about that I
learned from you
Charlie Gill from people in the media I
think it's clear there are lots of
questions that have yet to be answered
I think Americans deserve an answer to
those questions do you think they had
any role in your mother's defeat Russian
influence I think we don't yet know the
answer to anything around Russia and I
think we all deserve those answers so
why do you think your mother lost an
election that many people thought she
would win well clearly I worked very
hard for that goal so did your father
I'm deeply biased towards my mom I'm as
proud today want to know well I'm you
know for me Charlie I'm focused on the
future you know I think part of what I
hope to do with it's your world what I
hope to do with my work at the
foundation what I hope to do kind of
through my teaching which thank you for
mentioning that earlier is to help
encourage all of us to be focused on and
of what do we think our major challenges
are kind of what can each of us do you
know I think there's so much to worry
about today to ensure that we get to a
future that is you know healthier safer
more equitable I'm focused on that it's
an interesting time for the Democratic
Party though because they have to look
the new leadership and and people who
are prepared not only to run for
elective office but also to be a part of
building the party back at the local
state and national level and I'm really
grateful you know here in New York City
we have some fantastic dynamic Democrats
who are doing just that I have written
another book she persisted that was
partly inspired by Senator Warren
reading Greta Scott King's letter at
least attempting to read her letter on
the Senate floor so thankfully Charlie
we do have lots of strong Democratic
voices and lots of strong independent
voices I think who are raising awareness
about what they think is wrong on what
we do there is a possibility that
politics is is in your DNA
I hope the politics is in all of our DNA
and I actually I mean that deeply I
think again being a DNA is different
well I think it is I really I mean this
I think that kind of being a citizen
isn't something that just happens on
Election Day I think we have to stay
informed and engaged and I think
that's been kind of as true over the
last few months as it's been true kind
of throughout my life and I hope that
more people understand why I feel that
way and I hope more people kind of who
have been more engaged since Election
Day stay engaged we'll all be better for
that you're getting NASA Joe for sure
Chelsea Clinton thank you I know you
have our bonus section in the book yes
well thank you that's worth also taking
a look at Thank You Norah yeah thank you
so much for being here and Gayle will
talk to the two president Trump's
daughter Ivanka later today it will be
her first interview since assuming an
official role in the White House
assistant to the president you can see
the conversation tomorrow right here
only on CBS this morning any message
she'll see anything you want me to pass
along to Ivanka today when I see her
well then I hope we're kids are doing
well yeah I hope they're enjoying their
new home in Washington all right she
wishes the same for you that your kids
are doing well always